a nationwide manhunt continues this time
with ties to Las Vegas and this man seen
here is accused of a violent kidnapping
for what police say is the second time
the Grant Pass Police Department in
Oregon looking for 36-year-old Benjamin
Foster convicted of a similar crime here
in the valley back in 2019 but was
released nearly two years later Victoria
Saha joins us live in studio with more
on his lengthy record and the search to
find in Victoria Kirsten Fosters has a
lengthy record in Las Vegas dating back
to 2014 with several charges of domestic
battery the most recent conviction in
Las Vegas when he was when he kidnapped
and assaulted a woman back in 2019 now
he's done it again while trying to
escape police
extremely dangerous is how the Grants
Pass Police Department is describing
Benjamin Foster they have been looking
for him for more than a week as he has
wanted for attempted murder kidnapping
and assault he's accused of beating up a
woman he found on a dating app investing
It is believed he is still actively
using dating apps to lure women into
helping him Escape or finding other
victims this man also held a woman
against her will for two weeks in Las
Vegas back in 2019. Foster strangled the
woman and shaved her head he tied her up
using zip ties and duct tape the woman
was later able to escape when they went
to a grocery store Foster took a plea
deal and charges of battery with
substantial bodily harm and Battery
constituting domestic violence a judge
sentence fostered a 12 to 30 months in a
Nevada prison but with a credit of 729
days served and because of that Foster
was immediately released because of his
extensive record Grants Pass police say
Foster doesn't have much to lose if he
is caught he's a felon On The Run he
doesn't want to go back to prison he's
probably willing to do anything to stay
out of prison police did find Foster's
car about 20 miles away from Grants Pass
after their canine picked up his scent
they believe someone helped him get out
of the area it is possible he has
changed his appearance so take a good
look at his facial structure and eyes
I reached on to our district attorney to
explain Foster's plea deal and his
release from serving time I'm still
waiting to hear back I also reached out
to Metro and if they are assisting
police in Oregon but they say they
aren't Kirsten